authenticity is power
it is power because people pay attention
to authenticity you know a leader who is
facing some enormously difficult task
that he or she is trying to lead people
in who stands up and says i'm afraid
that's authenticity
which leads people because now they say
that person is afraid i'm afraid i'm
gonna listen
[Music]
so guy
speaking with you uh on and off uh this
this interview
reading your book and and
watching your different platforms you
come across as so authentic and so
and so genuine which i think is it is
very hard for a lot of us to to make
ourselves vulnerable
the same way i remember speaking with um
with jesse isler uh years back
and uh here also on on this show uh and
jesse isler he is um
he he made it he created an airline and
founded it and sold us above it but i
don't know if he might be even slightly
more famous for being married to sarah
blakely uh
to today
a wonderful person and and so is his uh
wife
and i asked him about
a piece of advice he would give to his
20 year old self
and
rather you know
he said you know it's very simple
make yourself
vulnerable that was the best piece of
advice he could he could give i know
it's a big question to ask you here uh
guy could you talk about your own
journey about making yourself vulnerable
making the decision to make yourself
vulnerable also
in public and perhaps some of the
bruises but also some of the
wonders that it has carried with it
yeah
what a what an amazing question i didn't
i don't i i have not met sarah blakely
uh i share a mutual friend with her
and um i never heard of jessie itzler uh
but and i never heard of somebody who's
well known and successful in saying
make yourself vulnerable
and but you know
the sunset's thrown me back because it's
it's such a powerful idea
and um
and so you know so simple to describe
and so hard to do
and
because because if so
i think that probably i know very little
about jesse other than his name
and that he said that
i i suspect stig
that
he is or was deeply loved by his parents
and or is deeply loved and
meaning
that he has no doubt
in in no doubt
he doesn't even it's not even a question
that he asked that he is
he he is loved and that he loves himself
the reason why i say that is that
what gives us the strength to be
vulnerable
is
i think the knowledge that when
we become strawberry jam on the mass
pike type of deal when when when life
hits us
sideways and feels like we've been
destroyed
we have the confidence to go out and
conquer even though we know that we're
going to be dealt
terrible terrible setbacks
and um
and and what what a so that's it's just
a i i'm kind of like in awe
of the power of that insight
and uh then i ask myself
so i'm going to go better to
um how i've dealt with vulnerability how
i got to make myself more vulnerable
and
you know maybe some learnings from that
and
you've really kind of stumped me in a
certain way it's stomped in a good way
because you've just thrown this it's
kind of a new thought to me that
shouldn't be that new to me
i as you were talking what came up for
me was brene brown
and um uh she has talked a lot about i
think the power of vulnerability
and in my case it starts with having
somebody who loves you deeply no matter
what
and i think that if many of us some of
us are lucky enough to have gotten that
from our parents
and if we didn't get it from our parents
hopefully we had a soccer coach or you
know maybe now a spouse or a significant
other who provides that
uh force for us if we don't have that we
don't have something to go back to when
life splats us in the face
the next thing i think that i go to
idea that i go to is
when we are so so somebody's listening
to this or i myself say to myself i need
to make myself vulnerable
i think that we need to titrate the
vulnerability so
there are many different levels of
vulnerable there is
standing out in the snow
is putting on your skis and just
standing in your skis there's going out
in the snow and pointing your skis down
the steepest slope in history all of
those are different levels of
vulnerability and they're sitting inside
in the warmth and not even putting your
skis on
and so you know i think that this sort
of in injunction to be vulnerable and
make yourself vulnerable to get success
it's saying get outside and think about
putting your skis on but it's not
telling you where to point the skis it's
not telling you whether you should ski
the blue slope the red slope or the
black slope
and so
vulnerable is not on or off and if
you're a type that is very scared of
making yourself vulnerable make yourself
a little bit vulnerable
and if you're already making yourself
vulnerable check if you're not you
shouldn't make yourself
more or less vulnerable so
i think that
in in many ways i would tell you i mean
the opposite perhaps of making yourself
vulnerable is sort of like staying in
shelter out of fear
and i actually think that there are many
aspects of my life stig that actually
have been driven by fear
i don't think that's a good thing uh i
think that uh fear does not help you get
anywhere in life fear is a kind of uh
not a helpful emotion i think that fear
is a helpful emotion when there's
something to be scared of
you know so if the avalanche is coming
down the hill then definitely be fearful
if you're walking down a dark alleyway
and there's a guy in the corner with a
knife definitely be fearful but to be
chicken little and to be worried that
the sky is going to fall on your head
when actually it may never fall
that emotion is
very unhelpful and i think that my
example perhaps demonstrates that you
can live actually quite a fearful life
and when i say fearful that's been
expressed in some very conservative
investing
an unwillingness to take huge huge um
huge risks for gain or even small risks
for gain but the answer is that even if
you do a little bit right you can have
some you can have a pretty damn good
life and enjoy a certain amount of
success
and i do think that the summer the
success that i have had is not because i
came out of a place of fear it's because
i came out of a place of being willing
to be vulnerable willing to fail
and then i guess i will just take you to
the writing of the first chapter of my
book
and so vulnerability comes with this
desire of honesty
and i was very heavily influenced by two
books both of them came to me by way of
uh monish pabrai and this amazing launch
that i had with him
one is power versus force by david
hawkins
the other is mahatma gandhi's
autobiography
uh and this power versus force david
hawkins talks about the power of being
truthful and the power of authenticity
and so you know authenticity is not some
cute
thing that you do to make the world
like you because you're being authentic
authenticity is power
it is power because people pay attention
to authenticity
you know a leader who is facing some
enormously difficult task that he or she
is trying to lead people in who stands
up and says
i'm afraid
that's authenticity
which leads people because now they say
that person is afraid i'm afraid i'm
gonna listen
because they they're identifying with
the emotion that i have and then maybe
they say i'm afraid here's what i'm
doing about it
is far better and real leadership than
saying don't be afraid you idiots when
everyone's thinking yeah yeah yeah easy
for you to say i'm absolutely very very
scared so
um as i was writing the first chapter of
the book i understood the power of
authenticity i understood the power of
truth and i had seen that mahatma gandhi
had written about going with prostitutes
and about um
eating meat despite being a divine hindu
and i had an issue that i wanted to work
out i had this terrible
career choice that i'd made that i kind
of wanted to keep buried for the rest of
my life and but then there's something
that happened
on i don't i felt i had to write about
it but i wrote about it telling myself i
don't know what i'm going to do with
this maybe i'll just go into my notes
i'll never i'll never look at them again
and then i don't know exactly what
happened i discovered that i had within
me the courage
to put it out there and deal with the
consequences and i think that actually i
did something that um
uh his uh four-hour work week guy um why
am i forgetting
yeah tim ferriss has a whole ted talk on
fear mapping
and actually what i had done was i had
fear mapped the consequences of making
myself vulnerable and telling the truth
about that part of my career
and
so i fear mapped it and i said well what
are the consequences of me going and
doing this
and i
figured out exactly the way tim ferriss
said is that
you know possible the worst outcomes
were not that bad second of all the
worst outcomes were something that i
could deal with and there were also all
these things i could do to mitigate
those risks and my fear was that i'd be
completely
a pariah in the financial world because
people would see this stuff and they
just say well we're definitely not
having anything to do with you as i
wrote about and so
that actually that capacity that i
discovered to make myself vulnerable in
the moment when i realized that that
chapter was going to form a part of my
book
i think set me on a fantastic path
and i'm really saying this not to teach
but to just to act as a winner as to one
example of that is that
the decision to make oneself vulnerable
i think i want to reassure
the listener
that decision is not something that is
forced on us
it's not like some part of my superego
says
you need to make yourself vulnerable so
now go and do it as if it's some school
master
it it's something that wells up from
inside
when the teacher when the student is
ready the teacher appears
so i think that the injunction going
back to jesse itzler about success being
uh vulnerability being at the root of
success
it's not about okay let me select one of
10 ways i can make myself vulnerable and
find one that would is really kind of
out there it's about
you know so so there's a
so when i when i don't have anything
better to do stig i read poetry i try to
read poetry and there's this poet
t.s eliot
who is um
i don't understand most of his poetry
just to be clear and i'm not some
literary
guy who understands everything but
there's a poem of his called
the love song of sir alfred prufrock
and then i want to go and say stig
that i don't understand the poem
but the poem evokes thoughts and
feelings in me and so
um there is a part of the poem where he
says do i don't i do i dare to ask the
question
to ask that question and i'm not quoting
the poem entirely correctly but he
evokes this idea of a guy who's on the
very tip of doing something he's on the
very tip of asking perhaps a woman in
his life whether she should marry him
although it's not clear that that's what
the pub is about
he's just on the cusp of you know you
have the person standing in front of
that
on that cliff and will he or won't he
jump
with the bungee jump or will he won't is
he ready to take that leap into the
unknown
and
i think that there's an instinctive
sense that we need to get around or get
better at to say yes
i'm never going to feel entirely safe
but this is something where i'm willing
to make myself vulnerable
and we've got to try and try we go we
got to try and titrate
the doses of vulnerability we give to
ourself shouldn't be so little that it
doesn't have an impact it shouldn't be
so great that it could destroy ourselves
we're going to get it wrong but what an
amazing thought and i've rambled a
little bit
but you've given me something ready to
chew on i mean that's gonna i'm gonna
probably dream about vulnerability now
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
you